opposition I don't mean to sound the
alarm but it's been almost eight weeks
since Hurricane Maria devastated Puerto
Rico but as the island works to pick up
the pieces some of those pieces are
spilling over into our country look
following Hurricane Maria the island is
primed for a mass exodus of what could
be 1 million people a sizable number of
whom are expected to settle in the state
of Florida people are leaving the island
coming to Florida Ohio Pennsylvania New
York because there's no hope no hope
folks forgive me but I have to say maybe
this isn't the time to talk politics
maybe our focus right now should be on
the people of Puerto Rico their humanity
and their loss and they shouldn't be
exploited to serve a political agenda or
partisan wait what did she say Chuck
roll that back people are leaving the
island coming to Florida Ohio
Pennsylvania and Florida Ohio
Pennsylvanians swing States alarm
[Applause]
Florida Ohio and Pennsylvania our swing
states to understand what this means
before I was concerned about Puerto Rico
but suddenly I am concerned about Puerto
Rico clearly Democrats are colluding
with a foreign power to influence our
next election and reshape the electorate
in their favor I don't mean to get
outraged but outrage of course the rand
mcnally map east does claim the Puerto
Rica is an American Commonwealth but
many experts disagree and by experts I
mean Americans a recent poll suggests
that nearly 50% of Americans don't know
Puerto Ricans are American citizens and
like climate change we got to hear both
sides now I don't know about you but
this kind of election meddling smells
like liberal shenanigans you know a
faint whiff of eucalyptus IPA with top
notes of storytelling podcasts and
insisting communism is different from
socialism I mean why else would these
people be leaving Donald Trump already
fixed Puerto Rico Chuck let's see the
proof paper towel three-pointer nothing
but net give me another one whoa that's
a paper towel to reporter right there as
they say in Spanish swish swish fish
and he didn't just fix it he nailed it
in fact President Trump gave his
administration a perfect ten for its
relief efforts but for some people like
my dad a perfect score just isn't good
enough
[Applause]
stay inside yourself saying don't let
him get to you
and while things must be getting better
down there the government bureaucrats
keep finding new problems to fix like
the schools and the drinking water and
the entire electrical infrastructure of
the central energy and power grid and
now every Hollywood floozy and Broadway
baby is seizing this opportunity to go
to Puerto Rico to virtue signal and
Instagram and show up Donald Trump like
their careers depend on it like JLo and
pitbull and I'm sure lots of people with
human names too but the worst offender
historical revisionists lin-manuel
Miranda the island is getting help from
the creator of the Broadway musical
Hamilton but Manuel Miranda visited San
Juan yesterday where he announced a
partnership with a non-profit group a
Hispanic Federation for a 2.5 million
dollar hurricane recovery fund he is
single-handedly I think doing a lot of
help yeah for Puerto Rico recovered I
see what's happening here do you big
elections coming up in 2018 and 2020 our
swing states are about to be invaded by
a million potential voters who are for
some reason upset with Donald Trump and
who benefits most Democrats
I have to do something but what can I do
to combat this attack on Donald Trump I
mean how does a bastard orphan son of a
whore and a Scots okay looks like I've
been sued fine all right fine
doesn't matter my mission is still clear
I'm gonna pull a reverse Hamilton and go
to Puerto Rico because I'm just like my
country I'm young scrappy and hungry and
I'm not throwing away a suit again all
right I see what's happening clearly
they don't want me to go down there well
they can't hide from Jordan Klepper when
I come back on Monday I'll show you
everything they don't want you to see
Puerto Rico here I come yeah
[Applause]